first of all though gentlemen a few
weeks ago we celebrated the wonderful
30th anniversary of Zelda which made us
all feel very old it's been 10 years
since it's a lot of princess came out
and it's out again with new HD visuals
rob crossley review the first he gave it
a nine out of 10 he did I know I like
point2 better than one of us when it
came in 10 years ago that was an
infamous review back then was it not why
did Jeff did it well it was around the
same time as the whole you know gaming
winch oh really was it was right around
that time that's why you really got axed
because I didn't give it that point two
extra if needed and Mike so you didn't
review it Rob reviewed it out of the UK
video reviews up on the website now but
you have them playing us yeah last
definitely what's your take on it what's
what's it feel like uh they're
definitely some things don't hold up as
well as I I mean I always thought those
first two hours were a slog right not as
much so they do take a couple of those
chores out that you're doing on the
ranch and whatnot you still have to hold
up hoard all those Gert yeah you can do
heard all those goats heard early Gertz
yeah okay that's annoying but I'm and
it's still I like it a lot but there are
some spots in between the dungeons that
I don't remember being as kind of
clawing as they are now uh that's just
as much they used to be but in hindsight
I don't remember as much how does it
control because this was a game came out
on this was the one that was like Game
Cube on we yeah we and then gamecube
right weekly so they did have an on
motion control version but what does it
feel like playing that game like 10
years later does it does it does it feel
like a good because there's so much
stuff in that game would like archery
and like horse riding like does it feel
that like it works Taylor's a little bit
janky it feels better than like what I
remember I remember I was kind of forced
myself to liking to like most motion
controls yeah we and then um the
gamecube felt fine the camera i kind of
member being a little wonky if you
weren't using z targeting i think it was
kind of hard to get linked to go
straight but the motion with the gamepad
the actual motion controls those
actually work really well just like they
do with the 3ds games and I like those
that's nice town I have to use like the
thumb stick to aim every time you want
to use the slingshot or the bow smashing
yeah we got a bunch of questions into
which I keep them coming in folks I do
at down your Dwyer on the twitch chat
there if you want to make sure I see it
and I got a couple of other little
questions about it i guess like this i
don't i don't even know how your review
a game like this when it comes out again
cuz it's like okay do we like I feel
like we have this conversation if a
couple of weeks now but this is so many
of these remakes but like how do you
judge a game based on like how it plays
taking a style do you take nostalgia out
of the equation completely can you do
that he better have but then like heady
like mechanically it's obviously ten
years in the past and doesn't have like
this it doesn't work as well Rob did a
good job of explaining how some of the
things that seem outdated in the old
Zelda game you know it's because they
may be are oversimplified but the way
that they exist within the game is
justified by the things they open up and
the things they allow to happen hmm I'm
trying to think of a specific example
but but yeah like it it might be a
little bit dated but it also has dated
in a way that it offers experiences that
we don't normally see anymore because
we've kind of graduated from that type
of game design yeah but yeah no I don't
think Rob really was influenced by a
nostalgia too much like he seemed to
make a pretty strong argument for why he
thinks this game makes sense right now
and why it's such a great experience it
was really divisive when it came out I
remember I wasn't so I didn't grab
nitwit Nintendo consoles and this was I
think this might have been the first
Zelda played was was winwaker but this
was the first I think I bought on launch
day and to me it was like okay I get
this I wasn't too much into like the
wolf aspect of it no one really is i
don't yeah do you think that it still
fondly remembered gang because people i
remember around that time we're really
looking for a realistic look Ryan Selda
game and then they got it but then a lot
of them didn't really seem to dig in the
end its divisive I mean I know kind of
like might describe the opening a few
hours are kind of crap for some people
and the same thing was said about
Skyward Sword and it caused a lot of
people to write the game off entirely
yeah but uh yeah i don't i don't know
like it people also do like it yeah
because it's dark right i mean it's a
side of the zelda universe that we don't
get to see very often Majora's Mask is
the only other game in the series I can
really think of that kind of delves into
sinister themes as it were yeah
so I think people really do appreciate
it for that reason alone in some cases
has sun and the chat says people finally
remembered for its dungeons that's also
something that I Rob brought up in their
view do you dive into a bunch of those
they still feel as fresh as they did
back in two thousand six yeah I like
them more than I remember I think I kind
of had that experience of taking you
know the rose-colored glasses off yeah
after playing last week there are a few
things that I don't like as much as I
used to but the dungeons definitely not
only how well they're designed in terms
of the puzzles themselves inside the
dungeons but I think twilight princess
was the first game in the series i
played were they really contextualize
the dungeon so it's not just this random
temple that you know the the sage is
built to or that was built to house a
sage and you know it's not this like out
of context thing it's it's just mansion
up on it on a mountain where the Yeti
lives it's a it's a mine where the
gorons live it's a it's like a actual
tree on the edge of the forest where all
these young monkeys are hanging out it
they did a really good job man yeah
they're like believable locations all
those the butts are still pretty and
maybe here they get me yeah oh that very
detailed butts good how does it look
actually how does it sound well they
both are very good I you had mentioned
how it's kind of it's a much darker game
overall and I think they the soundtrack
itself the score really really I don't
know if they've changed it too much it
just it sounds great and it kind of
emphasized that I think the older I've
gotten the more I don't love the art
style as much anymore but i love the
overall tone of the game I think maybe
when i was younger i just am i expecting
more of like a winwaker kind of
whimsical thing yeah and I I like this a
lot more that I've kind of grown up with
the series smashing there you go did you
hear that somebody found a there's like
a painting a framed painting in one part
of the game and inside that painting was
one of the concept art for the new Wii U
game oh really yeah they stuck that in
there wow so Islander was not just fan
today I think it was yeah it was like
just on gaff today right it was funny is
someone else in that thread put up a
photoshopped image with that Assassin's
Creed concept art from this very cordial
I'm gonna say reminded me that's pretty
good yeah yeah I wonder if there's a
bunch more wonderful next couple of
weeks people gonna start like data
mining the game 4
any clues on good luck are we gonna see
that news out of this year we better
kind of have to worry I yeah we really
do I mean I don't think the game's not
gonna sell if it gets pushed back but I
think a Nintendo needs good will and
that would be putting the game out this
here and you also saw the Justin a
walled the barrel and put up a great
interviewed for Spencer earlier today on
gamespot and he was talking about how he
believes the NX will be shown off at e3
this year is up pretty much set on it
that's that this stage is that like a
confident III is in set in stone but it
seems pretty concrete that it'll be
around that time whether they do it
through a Nintendo director something
like that yeah i mean III isn't it's
kind of a weird place to announce a
console these days it seems to be better
suited to games well someone almost
console successful consoles in the world
was an acid III and released the next
day so maybe saturday referring to a
sega saturn and ya know retailers didn't
even know that thing was going to be
available so like that I don't know III
think Nintendo has done a good job of
distinguishing what they do and what III
is over the past few years and I think
they're gonna maintain their
relationship and it'll probably be that
we hear about the console beforehand
right and then we see more extensive
demos of games at e3 with hands-on time
yeah that's kind of the way they do that
now I guess yeah yeah it's gonna be a
weird III but dot on the EA doing their
own thing and the pc gaming show who's
coming back for better or for worse
remember that i remember the
presentation that was weird it was weird
yeah i was like it was like our show it
was like a stage show which has lasted
for [ __ ] for hours or something I
know commendable effort but yeah maybe
it'll be better second yeah yeah anyway
we shall see at the electronic triple-a
but yeah if you're interested in
twilight princess let us know in the
comments below and what are the dog
what's up any were you doing over there
Sandy's last show by the way so he's
probably gonna start doing some good
nonsense honest boo what was that Bert
was up I don't want to leave I don't
believe either so yeah pull out all your
tricks today Batman alright make it look
real where yeah there you go look I'm
taking over camera work that's got some
gifts out of this show not really
hitting good work oh yeah let us know
what you think in the comments below